hurry so the battery might die any
second so we're gonna watch a trailer in
SuperSpeed yeah yeah we're gonna
fast-forward the whole trailer here we
go I'm Ryan by the way I'm Lauren by the
way we're gonna watch the neighbors
official veteran friend woman zakka
I've really been wanting to watch this
trailer so let's go play there's great
yes it's gonna be us one day you just
wait how awesome
we have to continue this on watching
noisy call me first they'll call the
cops this really looks like a mother fun
call the cops
everybody has caller ID Pacific Gyre
[ __ ] oh yeah well next to a college
like why are they opening you I'm Sam
Jackson and Jackie Brown
that looks like a total grab job I want
to see that I'm really looking forward
to that movie kind of like animal
household school I was in a sorority in
college and why would they just open a
frat house at a random place wow talk
about ability to not suspend your belief
good ah go watch it it looks like a
great [ __ ] time
yeah Zac Efron looks look I love how
game he is for this kind of comedy
it makes him like ten times cooler
comment on the fact that Zac Efron is
doing [ __ ] like this and the hedges like
doing nothing you talking about she's
doing like crazy dramatic or do you not
keep up to date with Vanessa Hudgens
career I don't really have an opinion
about her acting you're probably right
she's part Asian is she dad I think
she's like a little bit Chinese or
Filipinos hot oh dude
if you're new to the channel you gotta
subscribe oh my god it's like I'm here
somewhere thick after of course the
subscribe button what comes next Lauren
you comment and say how awesome I am
yeah do that I guess shout out died
after the comments who's it gonna be I'm
dancing I'm telling you what I mean
Jason Garcia
Oh Jason said you
it's a shout-out hey Jason so shout out
Jason like the Red Power Ranger [ __ ]
awesome dude did you watch Power Rangers
Lauren your airship I've ever seen asian
porn Lloyd you've never actually seen
any important or like gander did it I
don't know I just thought all Asian
people will one day look at Asian born I
know I only the part that I'm in yes
find that video good luck
you'll be about a search were very
awesome yeah they took curtsy a buddy
Murray g3g said something about the
three of us Sally Gerry died not you
okay so I'm not in this story southern
so just stay to the side no just okay
fine stay there just shut off for a
second yes she's over to you so thanks
for me thanks I'm just gonna pretend
I've been watching this video come on
this is cuteness at its top level yo
like two people with ADHD
thanks for that Murray G this is what
happens when you don't include more a
memory t EF fan nation said he wants a
shadow animation yeah the good nation of
thin yeah what is it efficient even mean
what is it's a nation of fans not like
you are band of something you're like a
ceiling I'm not me no sense well your
name god Lauren to cracka no thank you
crying feel the webbing the image you
have put in her mind I'm a nation of
people as ceiling fans there may be like
like that is that that's a fan no like
Asian people were really intellectual
people I don't understand what's
happening
now I'm good at that she's actually cry
a book hooking right into her eyes am I
always [ __ ] she's crying right now